on a donc la partie vitrine accueilli le
coin bureau pour donc l'étudiant une
petite kitchenette équipée d'un frigo et
enfin la partie sanitaire avec une
cabine de douche les wc ces études est
de 18 mètres carrés sont les plus prisés
sur le campus dijonnais problème il y en
a 400 il en faudrait cent trente de plus
pour satisfaire tout le monde cette
année les place en cité u sont chers et
au point d'accueil du crous et coups de
fil sur good feel quoi se prépare son
appareil pour vous dire combien vous
devez régler exactement pour qu'on a
besoin on a juste besoin de ce papier en
fait donné combien de coups de fil par
jour l'an cependant on ne les compte
plus on ne sait pas exactement combien
on en a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup qui s'inquiète des gens qui
s'inquiètent qui n'ont pas eu leur
dossier qui ne savent pas quels
documents il faut fournir et même avec
un dossier complet pas d'assurance
d'avoir un hébergement
cette année encore le crous a enregistré
trois fois plus de demande que ce qu'il
offre au niveau des appartements d'un
des très très grande demande donc la
foudre apparaît qu on réoriente sur les
résidences inoccupées et une chambre
faute d'appartements c'est ce qui risque
d'être proposé à ceux qui n'ont toujours
pas de logement attribué mais qui vont
pouvoir profiter des désistements d'un
désistement des désistements qui vont
arriver aujourd'hui on en aura qui
seront mis tout donc on pourra encore
faire de la proposition d'offre jusque
là rentrée on essaye d'être très réactif
et de publier au pilier pour que les
étudiants soient rassurés et une réponse
assez vite
et la réponse sera peut-être l'une des
150 chambre de ce pavillon sur le campus
fermé pendant un an il a été
complètement réhabilité